this is steve kaufman here i want to
talk a little bit about my favorite
subject which is language learning
um you know i was watching um on the uh
i was looking for something on the
internet
and it was in youtube and
probably looking at something related to
language
and i came across a youtube whereby
the this coffee break spanish had
received an award as the outstanding
language learning
podcast or website in britain or in
europe or something like that so i went
to the website and i checked out what
they offer
and a lot of it is i mean it's
predominantly from what i can gather
it's two scottish people a guy and a
girl speaking spanish and talking about
different aspects of the language
explaining the language
they have a little dialogue and
and other stuff of that nature i i must
admit i didn't spend a lot of time there
but
if i were learning spanish i would not
learn from two scottish people
and um i would not be intro lesson 62
they had singing happy birthday in
spanish i would not be the slightest bit
interested in singing happy birthday in
spanish
um
and they had you know today we're going
to talk about por and por and para
four but they're two different in
spanish
sometimes you use porter and sometimes
you use para i can't give you the rules
on it i don't even think about it when i
speak spanish
if i started thinking about it i'd get
totally tongue-tied i probably get it
wrong some of the time doesn't really
matter to me
um i i am beginning to think that i am
the odd man out when it comes to
language learning i um
although i'm heartened that when i read
things by stephen crash and he very
often agrees with me or i agree with him
but it seems most people don't
most people go at language learning
in very strange ways in my opinion i
cannot imagine listening to
these podcasts done by non-native
speakers
or like many of the others as well to be
perfectly honest the chinese pod
japanese 101 whatever has a lot of
english on it i couldn't listen to it
more than once and and to me you need to
listen to so much
and you need to listen so often
and and it has to be as soon as you're
able to understand the language it's got
to be authentic real language so that's
what we do on our podcast we have some
beginner stuff
for the absolute beginner
but a lot of it is just trying to get
ordinary people to talk that's all you
need
it's lively it's real people and with
the transcript and what we ask people to
do is to listen and read and then save
words and phrases it doesn't sound very
glamorous but it sure
it sure works i might be the odd man out
when it comes to how to go about
learning languages but on the other hand
i speak 10 languages
i remember i was visiting with a
university
and i was showing this professor one of
the very few people in university who
has shown any interest in what we're
doing
and he looked at it and he said oh
that's too difficult no one will do that
no one will say words and phrases i
thought to myself yeah but people go to
class spend a lot of money they sit in
class
they're given a photocopied
newspaper article they sit there with
their dictionary looking up words
they write them down in a list
and they do that and it's painful they
don't have any audio they don't
those words they've written down don't
contribute towards any further
interactive learning of any kind but
this particular professor says no people
will not come to link and will not do
uh what we asked them to do which is to
say words and phrases to a database
and listen and read
so i said well what do you do
so he shows me a slide show that his
korean students had put together
i mean there were about five words of
english in this slideshow some actually
in correct which doesn't matter but for
all the time they put into making this
slideshow they could have been listening
to english
um so i i think there's a lot of things
that like a lot of classes let's do
something that's kind of fun and games
in the classroom
i think a lot of people prefer to listen
to a spanish language podcast that's
half english or has a lot of english
explanation
maybe they feel that and we have the
same with with other podcasts that we've
been associated with
for learning
japanese there's always a lot of
learning english
lots of japanese explanation so i guess
most people are like that i'm the
exception no question i'm the exception
and
i i think though that that that my
sister certainly works for me
i mean if i look at what is the average
learner the average learner
you know you can't explain the language
you have to get used to the language
uh in german when i discovered i bought
a series of cds
which were natural conversations and i
was so excited to be able to hear real
people talking rather than textbook
material and i listened to it so many
times off over and over and i stopped
worrying about the grammatical rules and
the
the endings and
and so forth which i couldn't remember
anyway i don't believe you can explain
the language i believe you can only get
used to the language through enough
listening now
that's not to say some people wouldn't
consult a grammar book i know that uh
pedro you know commented on my blog that
you like looking up grammar fine look it
up in the book but you won't remember it
but look it up it'll remind you it'll
kind of
uh describe some things that you've
already started to notice and if you
haven't started to notice them then the
explanation will be largely meaningless
i mean let's not forget too that if
you're learning a language it means you
don't speak it very well
so that your main activity is going to
be listening
so that in the case of my russian i'm
enjoying listening to
you know russian audiobooks reading
russian watching russian movies
and and i think that's something that
anyone who's learning a language
um not in the country where that
language is spoken always has the
opportunity to enjoy
passively
you know absorbing the language
listening reading and so forth
even if they get together with native
speakers who's going to do most of the
speaking it's not going to be that the
person is learning the language so what
the first thing you have to learn is to
understand you have to be able to listen
and and if you do that and if you do a
lot of it
i mean if i had the opportunity to go
out if i'm learning russian and i had
the opportunity to go out with a group
of russians
i don't necessarily want to say too much
i'll sit there and listen to them what
i'll take away from that evening will be
all of their natural interaction that i
was able to hear in russia i might say
the odd thing stumble a bit whatever
good i'll try but it's not going to be
crucial so isn't it so much better than
if you have that as a recording
that you can listen to over and over
again if you have a transcript
that you can then
read and save words and phrases now it's
more fun to work with live people sure
it is and you should mix all of those
things into it but i just think we
should not underestimate you know the
the
large amount of time
that has to be spent
on basic input and input of meaningful
stuff and my criticism of many of the
podcasts that i've seen
on the web is that the content is not
meaningful even rob and bob show and
many of these things i
would not listen to them
and and what we try to do in our podcast
is to try to get those discussions that
native speakers are creating for us as
natural as possible and encourage people
just to listen to listen over and over
again
and i think that that is how you learn
languages but i think i'm in a minority
uh stephen krashen and me
but uh but at any rate yeah that was i
just have uh you know thought i should
say that a lot of the podcasts that i'm
seeing you know and there's been this
explosion of podcasting
in uh as part of this whole new form of
language learning
it's still more of the same
type of lesson approach that
i think is so unsuccessful in the
classroom
and so we're not going to change what
we're doing
even though i'm quite sure that the
other podcasts are easier for people
uh i'm not sure they learn
but they are easier and and i suspect
that people who are prepared to do what
we ask them to do to listen many times
to read the same text to save words and
phrases to study those words and then to
talk once or twice a week by all means
and to write i think writing is
tremendously useful
that that regime is going to get you
results and it can also be enjoyable but
it's not obviously it's not as easy as
listening to something that's half
english half spanish if you're learning
spanish or half english and half russian
when you're learning russian but i
cannot listen to something that's half
english and half russian
so
maybe i'm just unique maybe i'm just
different
but on the other hand
i am a person who speaks 10 languages so
maybe
my difference is not necessarily a bad
way to be different who knows i'm sure
i'll get
both positive and negative reactions to
this to this discussion thank you bye